- Hello Believe Nation,
I started the MentorMe series
with the goal to learn from
people who've done a lot more than us,
and by hanging around
them a little bit longer,
some of their mindsets, their attitudes,
their beliefs, the way
they think, seeps into us
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today, we're going to
learn from Gary Vaynerchuk,
pulling from his most
motivational clips from 2015.
Mentor me, Gary.
And as usual, guys, as Gary is talking,
if he says something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it
so that other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy!
(uplifting instrumental music)
- I hear people say, like, well,
how do I get in New York Times,
or how do I get that
meeting with that CEO,
and oftentimes, I just say
one is better than zero.
The steps it takes to actually get to
the biggest places in the world,
before you get a meeting with, you know,
Zucks, or Cuban, or Barry
Diller, or whoever you're
trying to have a meeting
with in the business world,
well, you've got to have
a lot of little meetings
to build up your cadence.
People are always like,
man, you've been on Conan, and Ellen,
and the Today Show, and CNN,
and Fox, like, how do I get that?
And I'm like, well, I also
did a thousand interviews,
it feels like, on videos that
got one or 19 or 137 views.
Like, my PR people and all
my managers and handlers
are really pissed at me,
because they're like,
why are you spending 15 minutes
doing these blogs that have six readers,
you know, every single day,
and you're passing on the
stuff that we're giving you
to be on CNN or New York Times?
I still, even today, am as happy,
and sometimes even more excited,
to be on a podcast or a video
blog that's only going to reach
100 people, because I'm always
about depth versus width.
Do want to go wide, or
do you want to go deep.
I want to go deeper with my community.
I wanted to give back to
people that were fans of me.
And so even today, where I
have more leverage than I did
three or four or five, six years ago,
to get bigger platforms, I
still work under the model of
one is better than zero.
To me, doing these interviews
is the process of the work
that so many people are
impatient and not willing to do.
Are you willing to take ten
minutes to get 195 views?
I am.
I don't know who you think you are.
When you've not gotten the exposure yet,
when you have not made your name just yet,
when you're still making the climb,
when you're not paying
attention 'cause nobody else is
'cause 217 people are watching the video,
I'm grinding when you're sleeping.
I did those 87s and 59s
and 137s and 813 views
day in and day out, day in and day out,
day in and day out, and continued to.
You may make a video on
somebody's video show
that has 89 viewers, but
one of those 89 viewers
may be a producer at CNN,
or, or, might be the CFO
of a big company that
you're trying to reach,
and so undervaluing just that one view,
it needs to be the right
view, but it's one view,
is a humongous mistake.
It's about having the humility.
It's about not saying no,
even when you've made it.
And the one is greater than zero concept
is something I'm proud that
I continue to execute on.
If you actually love what you're doing,
if you actually love it,
there's no friction to turn on your brain.
The only time I feel like
I have to turn on my brain
was when I was six to 22 years old
when I was going through the bullsh--
education system of America.
Right?
That's when I felt like I
had to turn it on, you know,
to appease horse crap that
didn't match my reality,
but ever since that day, when like, yay!
And I went into like, you
need to buy this pinot grigio.
The second that started in May of 1998,
there's never been a day
that I've had to activate.
It's always on.
And I don't mean always-on
buzzword marketing, it's that
I love what I do so much
that there is no friction
to turn it on, even when I
am landing at two o'clock
in the morning from a
flight that's delayed
like the other night,
and then going directly into
it at 6:30 in the morning,
because the fire is so deep
inside, you love it so much.
You know, you don't need that jumpstart.
- [COLSAUCE] Aimee asks, a
professor once said to me,
"It's better to be a big
fish in a small pond."
Do you agree?
- Aimee, this, you know,
I'm going to be very upfront
on this question.
This is a good way to bang out the show.
That sounds like a loser professor to me.
It's small-time thinking,
I don't subscribe to it,
there's a lot of practicality in it,
right, there's...
It's a lot easier to be the
most successful businessman
in St. Louis, Missouri, than
it is to be in the world,
right, so I understand the thesis,
but honestly, that, to
me, is very conservative,
not in my DNA thinking.
That could be great
advice for a lot of people
who are delirious and think
they're better than they are,
though I love to drive through
self-esteem and optimism,
and I think early in your life,
you should absolutely shoot for
the highest stars that you can.
I think as life moves
on, and time moves on,
you need to become more practical,
you've got bills and kids,
and all those kind of things,
but to start off one's career
in the first 20 years,
call it 'til you're 40,
to be in that thinking,
I think that limits.
There have been so many
people who've hedged
and settled in their lives, and honestly,
I'm not the kind of
character that's going to
play in that kind of sphere.
I'm going in a different direction,
it's what comes natural to me,
but it's also because I think I can be
the biggest and the
baddest in any game I play.
It's just how I'm wired.
I think this comes down to...
It's probably very good advice to some,
and it's probably
atrocious advice to others,
and this is why I continue
to say, if I could inject
anything into anybody, it
would be self-awareness,
because it would help you
answer this question, because
for a lot of people, it's
probably really solid advice.
For me, and for many of you watching this,
it's crap advice.
Being a dick about it. I
know I'm sitting in a room
full of number two's, three's, and four's.
There's so many people in
this room that are like,
going to be dominant,
like, could be dominant,
number two, three's, and
four's, and I'm pissed
that the narrative now is that
you need to be a number one
and have your company, because
a lot of people are going to
lose or leave money on the table...
Because that's just the narrative.
I really do think you have to
audit who you actually are.
You can look at like, how people roll,
and like, it's great to admire
and things of that nature,
but it's so damn important.
You need to bet on your strengths,
and don't give a f---
about what you suck at.
Way too many people in this
room are going to spend
the next 30, 40 years of their lives
trying to check the
boxes of the things that
they're not as good at,
and that, you're going to waste
a f---load of time and lose.
To stick to like, your
DNA, because the truth is,
if you want to be an anomaly,
you've got to act like one.
You know, like...
And so, that's it, that's what I got.
So thanks for having me.
Action or enthusiasm.
The truth is, my friend, m squared,
can I call you that, Mister Money,
the real answer to that
question really is, both.
The funny thing is, I know tons of people
with massive enthusiasm,
and they can't execute sh--.
On the flip side, I know
people that can execute A's on
all their papers, but without
that passion or bravado,
or fire, they're only
able to get limited return
on that investment of execution, so to me,
I'm probably a 60/40,
action/execution 60,
enthusiasm 40.
I know a lot of people might not get that,
but the truth is, I'm way more proud
of my execution skills.
All this, all this charisma...
Hides what I really am,
which a hardcore executer.
Don't forget, I had
executed a large business
before I ever hit the scene.
I was already 30 years old when I started
Wine Library TV, and
started that whole process,
and so, I'm a 60/40
execution, enthusiasm, action.
I might even be a 65/35.
Heck, as I sit here, maybe I'm a 70/30.
What I would say the hustle is to me
is that when you have
passion around something,
that you are squeezing
every last bit of the
juice out of the orange.
Right?
To me, hustle is maximizing the energy
you're putting into somebody.
I'm blown away by people
saying that they're hustling,
and they want to achieve
these great things,
and then their actions don't match.
It's like saying you
really want to lose weight
while eating a Big Mac, right?
So to me, hustle would be
putting all your effort
into achieving the goal
at hand, and for me,
that means making every minute count.
Hiring a full-time
assistant who is, I mean,
Friday night didn't happen
because I was hustling.
Like, every minute, like,
if I miss my 15 minutes
to tape the show, I've
missed my 15 minutes,
because there's so much hustle in my day.
There's no, you know, there's no like...
There's no hanging out.
There's no like time where I like...
If I get to do like one joke with you guys
as I'm walking in between meetings,
we like find that to be a
rare acquaintance situation,
like, like, occurrence, not acquaintance.
Hustle is putting it all on the line.
Hustle is waking up one day,
the day before you die, and
realizing you gave your all,
into the parenting of your children,
the building of your businesses,
the philanthropy that you wanted to do,
whatever you define, it's
just, you know, all in.
Emotionally and executionally,
in theory and in strategy,
and in execution.
My dad taught me word is bond.
I've said it a couple times for the people
that watch me a lot, they know this,
that when I walked into
my dad's business at 14,
let's just say I was a little
bit of a bullsh-- artist.
And, you know, a lot of the charisma
and the showmanship and the salesmanship
that a lot of you enjoy,
and I appreciate that,
also comes with being full of crap.
It's got a very similar cousin DNA,
and I'm glad, I got very lucky,
let's call it what it is,
I do not think I'd be as
honorable or as good of a dude
without my dad's correction
of, you make a commitment...
I'll never forget it.
You make a commitment, you buy 50...
When I started buying wine.
You buy 50 cases, no matter
what, you take those 50 cases.
If you say I'll take those 50 cases.
If the market changes,
if it gets an 84 in the Wine Spectator,
you take it, you eat it, you drink it,
your word is bond, and
because I play the marathon,
not the sprint, long-term businessman,
that's helped me a lot,
because I've kept relationships
forever because sticking to
it has mattered quite a bit.
I think that I paint a
narrative of me wanting
to buy the Jets for 30 years,
that when I buy the Jets,
everybody's going to freak the f--- out.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, right?
And so like, and that, I'm sure,
on some level keeps me
motivated, you know,
there's a real dirty secret.
I'll go deep on you guys here, like,
I don't give a f--- if
I buy the Jets, right?
Like, I love the process.
I made a video four years
ago that sits in the cloud,
hopefully it doesn't disappear,
where I literally talk about, I actually,
this is the worst day of my life,
and it's the whole narrative
of the day I buy the Jets,
how upset I am, because
I love the climb, right?
And that's what I'm here for.
Like, that's why I'm even here.
I love the climb.
I love, like, talking
out stuff with peeps,
like I love the climb, I love the process,
and by creating such a heavy North Star,
you know, it's creating a
game where I can, you know,
keep climbing without ever
really having to change it.
I feel like resetting your North Star,
I'm a very big, shoot for
the moon, land in the clouds,
I feel like always having that North Star,
it has made me a much more
honorable, legacy-driven
entrepreneur, because I'm
trying to go for this big thing,
and a lot of things are going
to happen in the next 40 years,
so skimming an extra 50k as a
salesman isn't going to help me,
you know, because that person
might help me in 13 years
when they're xyz, and so,
I think it is a mechanism
that I created for a
couple different reasons:
one, the Jets represented,
to me, becoming American.
And, in a weird way,
it's like the ultimate Kickstarter, right?
Like my real plan is, if I'm like 75,
and I feel like I can't get there,
I'm just going to ask
everybody to help me.
(audience laughs)
I feel like if I can infect enough people
with the narrative, everybody's
going to want to kick in
their five, three, eight cents.
I'm a big fan of going
all in on your strengths
and outsourcing or not
focusing on your weaknesses.
I, I think you've got it pegged right.
I think the one thing is...
Sometimes it's obvious, right?
Don't get caught in the obvious,
meaning, it's obvious to you
that you suck at accounting.
It's kind of easy, right, it's math...
You probably also don't
want to or like doing it.
That's easy.
It's the thing that's in the
shadows, that's not as obvious.
There's something you're doing right now
that a lot of people
could do better than you.
It's easy when you're an F at it,
and you know you need an A.
But what about the fact that
you might be doing something
right now at Tiger or somewhere else
where you're a B at it,
but you could afford to
have somebody be an A at it.
That's where people miss the mistakes.
So, it takes deep self-awareness.
You know, I'm not a big
believer in like, try, try,
try harder, be better
at this thing, I think
it's a waste of resources,
energy, and happiness often.
Now, if you get off on that kind
of thing, like, persevering,
knock yourself out.
Roll how you want to roll.
But for me, big believer in
betting on all your strengths
and trying to find complements
to your weaknesses.
- [WHoltzman] Young Entrepreneur asks,
would you ever automate your position,
delegate to as many people as it takes,
and spend 95% of your time fully
engaged in family and life?
- Absolutely not.
Is this Young Entrepreneur?
Young Entrepreneur, let
me tell you something
from Old Entrepreneur,
which is I love the process of the work.
I love the grind.
I love the climb.
You know, I love the idea of
getting to buying the Jets
moreso than buying the Jets.
It's the process.
To delegate out what I love
would defeat the purpose.
Of course I want to spend
as much time with my family
as possible, but that
would be lying to my soul,
if I didn't do what I want to do,
and what I want to do for a
living is build organizations,
build companies, create
commerce, be a salesman,
and be a guidance counselor, HR character.
Social commentate and put out content.
I would suffocate if I couldn't put out
the work that's needed to
accomplish the things that I want.
Psst!
The problem, Young Entrepreneur,
especially when you're
a young entrepreneur
is people want stuff, right?
They want the bling bling here, right,
they want the cool-ass kicks,
they want the car, they want the jet,
not the Jets.
They want stuff.
I don't want stuff.
I want the sweat and the
pain and the gratitude
and the, you know, happiness
that comes along with the work.
I want the work.
I don't want the stuff.
- Thank you guys so much for watching!
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know
what got you fired up
most about this video.
It's hard not to be motivated
after watching this one,
but what was your favorite clip,
what did you take from
this that you're then
immediately going to pour into
your business and your life?
Leave it down in the comments below.
Super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to César Bonilla,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and
tweeting that picture out
about it as well.
I really, really, really,
really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching!
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(air rushes forcefully)
- [Steve_Campbell] Roberto asks,
what do you feel is a
bigger obstacle to success,
a lack of time, or a lack of capital?
- Roberto, this is a tremendous question.
I think the biggest obstacle to success
is a lack of optimism.
That question in itself
is the problem, my friend.
Right?
You're looking at two things
that are both negatives,
and guess what, both
of them are obstacles.
When I started winelibrary.com
transformation for my
business, I had time I worked
my face off every minute,
but we didn't have a whole lot of money
in our profit center, so
it took more time, right?
It's just the way it is.
Today, I have more money,
but boy, don't I have time,
but neither, ever, ever
will be an excuse for me,
and so, just to drill
this through the throat
of the Vayner nation, that's right,
I went that graphic, don't smile, D-Roc.
Here's the bottom line.
I refuse to allow you to get
an answer to the question
because both of them are firmly square
in the excuse column, and I
have no patience for that.
There will always be problems.
Let's talk about a million other things
that are a way to stop success.
The health and wellbeing
of your family members,
so it takes your mind away from execution.
The country you live in's government
and political, you know,
concepts at these moments,
a la startups in China
that I've invested in
that got traction, but
then people that were
wired into the government
decided to not allow it
to happen, and then the
startup disappeared.
Not as easy to be an entrepreneur there.
It's still a communist country.
Sorry, it just is.
And so all these things
can be problems, right?
There's a competitor
with a billion dollars
who's also skilled and
punches you in the mouth
and knocks you out in the first round.
Right?
The world changing.
I mean, there's just a
million obstacles, right?
The media.
One bad coverage of you.
A moment in time.
You know when I think about it a lot?
You know what I think about a lot?
Let's get really real.
This is why we did this show.
I always, I'm a human being,
and I always think about
a moment in time.
What if I just say the wrong
thing at the wrong time.
Right?
What if I call out China for
being a communist country
in an episode while I'm
on a rant, and somebody
who's watching doesn't
like the way that tastes,
and it takes away a business
opportunity for me in China
in seven years, even though
I'm not trying to zing,
it's just things that I saw.
What if, what if, you know, what if...
What if I look down on my
phone while I'm driving,
even though I've really not
done that, and I hit somebody,
and I kill them, and
that becomes the story.
And like, forget about the story,
about what you think of me.
I will never recover from
that, because I killed somebody
because I needed to check a tweet.
These are moments in time.
So there are so many things
that can keep you from
being successful, right?
The people that you invested
in having something bad
happen to them, so it slows you down.
My friends, there are a
million reasons why not,
but there's one great reason why,
which is, you've just got to persevere,
no matter what it is.
It's just the way it is.
It's hard being an entrepreneur.
It's hard building a business.
Everybody thinks it's so easy
that there's an entitlement.
There's a disaster.
Zinging China?
Here comes my US zing right now.
There is an insane generation
of 18- to 25-year-olds
right now that think they're
entitled to having a business
because they saw the Social Network movie,
and everybody's decided if you're a kid
and you know what tech is,
because you used Instagram early on,
you're entitled to
actually build a business.
Building a business is hard,
and you know what makes it really hard?
Everything that happens
every day of every moment.
So.
You can pick time, you can
pick money, as the one or two
things that you think stops
you from winning your game,
but the truth is, there's
a million reasons.
99% of businesses go out
of business for a reason,
and that reason is, it's hard.
And so, if you're watching this show,
I've got a sense of who you are,
and you need to start
creating layers and layers
and layers and layers of skin
to be able to get through,
because the glamour of
being an entrepreneur,
though, goodness, you
know, you get very confused
by my optimism 'cause it's my optimism,
I can't help it, it's just how I roll,
it's probably one of the
variable one percent reasons
why I'm successful, but
please, don't get it twisted.
This is hard.
Every day is hard.
And if you don't have the
stomach to weather the storm,
you will not be
successful, and by the way,
let me throw you a real weird curve ball.
And that's okay.
People have to look
themselves in the mirror
and understand if they're a
number two, three, four, five,
six, seven in an organization that has
differences of being a number one,
but maybe that's where your skillset sits,
maybe that's how you make
your fortunes and happiness
and all the things that
you're looking for, and so...
That question got me
going a little bit, Steve,
because it's under the context of excuses,
and I will never make an excuse.
Everything that's a problem with me,
everything I don't achieve,
everything that's the
problem with VaynerMedia,
everything is my fault.
And I...
I succumb to that, and I respect that,
and I actually think that's
the way it should be,
and so...
No excuses, my friends.